hello everyone um yes i'm going to guide
you through this wonderful journey we
had at adjen for finding for autism
marketplaces
a quick intro about myself i joined igen
around three years ago i'm heading data
science there before i had a career in
our space for around 10 years
um started barcelona engineering and i'm
from mallorca which i think is relevant
given that we are in germany
um if you don't know again just let me
just took two minutes uh sorry one
minute to say about something about it
ajin is an european company it's a
fintech we do at the core pricing uh
payments we also offer financial
services all this api based everything's
digital
we are all around the world uh and and
we're quite big last year we processed
uh more than 500 billion euros through
our service and we serve ubers spotify's
netflix's delivery hero flixbus for
example these companies
and i'm here to talk about
machine learning for fraud detection and
when people think about payment
processing they immediately go into
transaction risk which is a setting
where
you have a well-known seller say flixbus
and you have people shopping in
onto them right
in this i think it could be
you always trust the seller that's the
important bit and it could be that the
shopper is malicious say they bought a
batch of stolen cards on the deep web
right so we have algorithms at the gate
to make sure that well they don't go
through right
we also have an offering for
marketplaces and on this setting think
about ebay for example we process all
the transactions on ebay
and in this setting you have another
data point which is
um sellers but the seller you don't know
that well right you do a kyc process
which is everything automated you gather
information like the bank account like
the email like the passport and then
they start processing and you see this
interaction between shoppers and sellers
but in the setting it could be you don't
need to take for granted that the seller
is uh is not malicious so it could be
that actually there's some bad people
doing uh selling right
um so we built something for that to
help our merchants we call our customers
merchant merchants because we are b2b
and we built a thing called score
that has this flow
just this very high level overview
the idea is that the the main agent
platform is built on java and postgres
um and that's what exposes the endpoints
to our customers and then it's served by
a big data platform where we massively
use python to help on the decision
making right so in this setting we would
use kyc databases accounting databases
and we do some sort of online community
detection think about it as some quick
and easy graph uh algorithm
and then we could also from the big data
platform use algorithms to find weird
patterns that could point out to
malicious behavior we send those signals
and then we compute a risk score that
our customers can see to see if the
sellers are actually
malicious or not
on this talk i'm going to cover this bit
which is the part we do in python
we use big data a lot so we're very
heavy on spark over hadoop
and yeah i'll get you through the
journey that we did when we tried to
solve for that
first
i wanna i wanna tempt you with a little
quiz so
here's a toy data set and i want you to
think for a moment what do you think
here is odd what's an anomaly
now most of you
actually have seen five and six
being very lonely miserable there and
it's true they are what they call what
we call uh local global outliers right
um
the groups at zero and four they are
pretty well behaved same shape same
color for everyone there
um group number three is weird because
it's the same color but different shape
so we cannot say anything but group
number one and number two you really see
there's a data point that doesn't fit
right that's what we call a local
anomaly and that's what we try to find
out with those algorithms we're not
trying to find out the global anomalies
we cannot say anything about them
they're just lonely we're trying to find
who is different within their context
so these are the anomalies to do that
i'm going to use an example which i
think is the best way to actually
guide you through that
a significant shopper and what is a
significant chopper
you expect shoppers to have a certain
revenue on a seller if someone actually
buys 95 of the sales of a certain seller
that might not be adequate right so
yeah so i think here in the joke if you
buy ten thousand euros is that a lot
well if you buy if you're buying a
diamond ring maybe not
but if you go to favor maybe yes and if
you're not dutch probably you'll know
what favor is but they are proud of
their cuisine and basically is this
they serve cold stuff fried from long
time ago they love it
so
yeah don't don't spend ten thousand
euros on that a month
um so anyway what you really see there
immediately is that we can use the
average transaction value which i would
shorten for atv so if it's an uber right
it's 15
if it's electronics 500
and the merchant's volume right how big
is that store and you can use these two
features to say okay what's going to be
the shopper ratio that i expect for a
normal shopper right and we're trying to
do that and that's what we did and and
then like a coyote we just went there
and just hit plants and and failed
miserably until we got it done
right so the first thing you want to try
it out is what basically pumps 95 of the
artificial intelligence systems of the
world which are if statements so you
build a rule and you say well a bucket
if it's that atv and this atp and this
volume and this volume
but that as you can see already there is
going to not end well if you want to
have some
performance because you need to put a
lot of notes
for the record just it's going to be
handy later this basically means that
this toy data set you're going to slice
up in different areas through lines
right
um what's with rules well if you want
some detection performance you need to
put a lot of nodes and if you put that
in production that's not going to end
well so probably rules are not the best
choice eh
detection performance even with a lot of
nodes is never going to be
the best that you can get out without
with other techniques
the good thing about it is that we
humans don't trust machines and we feel
good about understanding what they do so
a rule is always understandable so yeah
it's nice regulators love this for
example right
anyway that's not the plan let's move
forward try something different
clustering right the idea with
clustering if you're familiar with those
algorithms k-means or http scan is you
basically put together all these points
are similar and the algorithm handles it
right
what's good and bad about that well what
is good is that you can put more
features you're not any more bound to
use atv and volume because you can just
put more in the matrix and that will
that will work
um what is bad is about the boundaries
um maybe maybe let me make a metaphor
there with uh the billionaires in space
last summer if you i don't know if you
followed but it was a bit ridiculous
they were having this fight about who's
going into space because when going to
80 kilometers up and the other was going
100 kilometers up it doesn't matter the
atmosphere fades out right so it's just
a convention so when you have this uh
fading out it's difficult to establish a
boundary clustering kind of get a bit
lost there
but moreover we thought
hang on a second they didn't ask us to
detect uh clusters they wanted us to
detect anomalies so this is just like a
means to an end uh maybe we just
complicate in our lives so we said okay
move forward next plan
then we try to say well what's better
than a rule and it's not clustering a
very simple linear system
um what is nice about it is that even if
you're allergic to equations you can
understand that one
and basically you have two coefficients
three coefficients and offsets and one
coefficient for the volume and one for
the atv and you try to establish a bit
where you should be and have a
prediction on the ratio right
so what is good and what is bad about it
the good thing is that well it's really
explainable because you can see a and b
tells you how much you're putting in the
decision ink for for each feature
good and bad it depends if you have
borders linear systems is not going to
behave well if you don't have borders
and and you're bound to have one not
polynomial features then you might get
it
but the detection performance wasn't
good
so what we tried next was
random forests and random foreigns are
nice and if you recall the title of the
presentation it was called shallower
learning so the idea is
you might be thinking random forest is
not a non-supervised learning algorithm
it's a supervised learning algorithm i
need labels what you can do is
uh try to predict the ratio based of the
past and do an average
sort of average or shallow learning on
the on the labels um so you want to be
very precise on your context that would
be the features like volume and atv and
you want to be imprecise on your target
say the the the shorter ratio
so you do that
and and we like that a lot
there's a certain explainability
embedded because you can do uh feature
significance
and you can put more features um we use
a spark pi spark ml for random forest
which works nicely for especially for
shallow cases
um you can embed categories if there's
boundaries or non-boundaries you can
still do something detection performance
is actually quite good and it's fully
unsupervised in a way that you can just
throw the full data set onto it and the
labels are actually what you observed in
the past
let me give you an example in for
actually production case
this is a real life significant shopper
we have 800 million rows uh 14 input
features one target variable and we
distributed with spark 16 executors and
36 minutes training time
of course this is a visualization that
is downsampled because you're not seeing
800 million rows here
ended up looking like the uk totally
fortunate um
and i'm asking here where are the
significant shoppers so you might say oh
big bubbles or maybe
people stick it at corners
no the algorithms find the stuff
all over right and this is the this is
the magic of it
so did we solve the problem well not
fully um we still need to validate the
model right we just took a blind guess
and we just threw the whole data set
into an unsupervised setting and we
tried to get a prediction that made
sense and manually inspecting everything
looks good but we don't have proof
and what happens if the the behavior is
actually more than one dimension because
here we have color and shape but the
random force you have one target
variable only one so what can we do
about it
and we went into the next plan which was
using we are data scientists we like
complicating things so we went into
neural networks and we tried to do the
same trick with shallow learning over
neural networks
and i know what you're thinking you're
saying hang on a second neural networks
tablet data
doesn't work
right
but it does because if you're using
heavy regularization it's kind of these
cases where you can actually use it you
can look at this paper which has been
recently updated it's a great
introduction on when when you can
and not use neural networks for tabular
data very few cases by the way
we use architecture you might be
familiar called an out encoder the idea
is that you have a bottleneck that's
imposing regularization into the into
the
the data set
okay
um
sorry about that
shall i
off and on again
you guys see it
um
thank you for hanging on
hopefully we fix it soon
i asked they didn't allow me
all right
was what a try
okay so
so we wait
okay so we hang on all right
okay so sorry we just try to wait a
couple of minutes if they get it fixed
so
[Applause]
i'm not going to move i'm not going to
do anything
so i was saying sorry about that
out encoders right so out encoders is an
architecture of a neural network that
basically imposes a middle layer that
it's it's reduced it's a bottleneck and
that basically creates embedding that
compress in a way the input signal then
you decode it back right
because we wanted to have this trick
around learning very well our context
and learning our behavior on the average
we actually kind of we gave a twist on
it and we customized the loss function
and we created a
scoring equation that could help us find
those local anomalies
uh we did that with the keras interface
over tensorflow and uh we used our spark
and
python
well did we solve the problem we haven't
yet validated right it's still the same
problem as before we just have a bit of
a leap of faith that the the model is
doing a good job
um now we entered into scalability
problems because you cannot really use
spice park melt to do out encoders
and if you use tabular data in my video
you have certain volatility
with the gradients on your neural net
um we are engineers we went
and tried to solve for this volatility
we used
ensembles so we run 16 next at the same
time we average out
and the scale eligibility we get in
there we experimented with barrier mode
on spark that could help us by shuffling
the weights
but we haven't yet validated the model
so that's something that we did last
year
how do you validate unsupervised
learning how do you hypertune a
supervised unsupervised learning
algorithm that's a hard question right
so we created our own test chamber we
we created a data set that had
statistical properties crafted to the
things that we wanted to see and then we
tested the algorithms to have a
benchmark
we were very happy with that because we
actually found the bug and and that bug
was around the treatment of our
categoricals so we had to actually
change the equations
and
yeah i put the meme there because
people asked me whether there was a i
just put this from wikipedia just to wow
people it's not these are three
equations so these are the stuff that is
running in production right now
and
yeah maybe you want to see how it works
in reality they think
let's do some cases that we have seen
through score and how we can help
marketplaces find fight fraud
this is one
where we see that the account is very
young
that we have seen unusual chargeback
ratios a single shopper did 90
of the volume that's already quite the
hint
low atv and repetitive amounts what
happened there is
people inflating their rating on as a
seller through just little volume
themselves and then they have a great
five-star score and then scan people
that can happen that's platform of use
another case is account takeover
uh basically they store your credentials
they change possibly your bank account
and here we see a change of kyc signal
and a sudden change on your behavior in
this case a spike in sales
could be for
most cases fortune is not the case it
could be money laundering
authorization rate
prepaid cards
it could be a fraud rink where we see
people actually that are very connected
through sharing say emails or bank
accounts or whatever and actually well
they have
little they don't have shopper variety
they have refusals and stuff like that
so what is next for us did we completely
fully solve the problem no we didn't
because
if i started right on i was the example
case where i started with the
sellers and shoppers network very simple
network what we did with these
algorithms was basically to isolate
every seller and look at their
surroundings and then found an embedding
or find some sort of prediction around
it which you can totally see as
something like that as a disconnected
network right same thing but we're
losing some power there right if you go
back here you might say hang on a second
there was one
shopper that was a froster that was
connected to a seller that was also a
thruster what if they are the same
person and even worse what about the
people that transacted with them right
so that's why we own that that's why
we're going full in uh with graphs um
so investing hard with that um
ideas that we can also mix up kyc
attributes and behavior and have way
more prediction power and have
algorithms do a better job
and that was my last slide thank you
very much
yeah that's my linkedin if you want to
connect and just shoot a message say
that you've been here so i don't you
don't try to sell me anything
and
and and yeah i'm happy to answer any
questions thank you
[Applause]
thank you
uh thank you for the uh amazing talk we
have some questions online so i'm going
to read them
uh i wasn't aware of unsupervised random
forest which library did you use
yeah by spark so by spark but ml
that's nice because it distributes on
the on all the
machines that we have
can you explain what you used as a
target in the random forest as a random
as a target in the random forest yeah so
what you use is uh you have seen in the
past the the ratio of the shoppers right
in this case
so that data point in the past is that
you would use you would try to predict
that right uh just the average not very
you don't want to overfit that's the key
isn't random forest a supervised model
maybe you meant isolation forest
random forest is a supervised model but
again if you don't if you use the labels
as i want to predict in the average this
you can treat it as an unsupervised
thing you don't have a label to say that
happened right
what graph ml uh machine learning
globally are you using
um good question um for graph ml we're
going big with pi torch geometric yeah
we like it a lot
did you try to make the problem a
supervised learning by using mechanical
torque to create labels or refund and
customer support ticket yeah so we do
have in the end labels coming back from
our customers when they say oh that
actually was a fraud case this isn't
that
the question so the problem was is
twofold right the first is the call
start problem when you start putting
this thing out you don't have any any
feedback so you need to have something
there and the second is uh well they're
gonna be labeling things that they have
seen and also they have some biases when
you have humans in the loop they want
you know label things here or there
what we use it we use those labels to
track performance right so if we see a
detection method that for example has a
very low uh we call it interest rate so
we have a you know a thumbs up downflow
so if we see that the detection that has
a has a low interest rate then we try to
iterate on it and see what's going wrong
what happens when a fraud is that
detected are you contacting authorities
or just sending the information to your
customer no this score is for customers
so for example um if we see that
happening on gofundme for example where
we pilot it with gofundme to to build
this stuff uh they could take care of it
is their problem
all right thank you
so i don't have enough time for the rest
two of the questions but uh you can ask
from here
does anybody have a room in the room
have any questions
all right yeah we also have a booth
upstairs and i'll be sitting there so if
you want to just come and chat that's
also fine
it's really hard to understand you
yeah so
yeah of course uh the thing is that at
aging we have a different philosophy
where we just don't jump straight into
vendors we try to see for ourselves so
what we did for example was to
um use what we had in this case uh spark
and graph frames on top of it try to do
certain analysis and see what it would
work
but we think figuring out so neo4j could
be an option we go for it might not be
we'll see
any more questions
yeah so the idea is that very is low
right but uh but
yeah but it's not my fault right it's my
customer's fraud so i'm not i'm not
happy to close
yeah but
we don't we don't train on it right if
you are going there with imbalance uh
it's more to say right from all these
cases how
how many of them were false positive
that's our biggest polluter right
and then if we have a big high false
positive ratio is when we try to see
okay we need to do something better here
can you use like
some of your
cross-client information to help with
the
validational frauds
excellent question
um we imagine we're super
open and transparent in the way what how
we deal with data right and we consider
our data to be in the hands of our
customers we just use it for them so
it's it's an opt-in scenario where they
say yes we want to check right and then
you can merge and see what's going on
with all the exposures that we have
think well ebay wix gofundme liboncua
and all that right
but we don't push it or we don't do
shady stuff with it
all right one more question
i have a question so how did you handle
pi information like the kyc details for
the customers especially when storing it
in the graph database yeah indeed that's
a very very good question um
[Music]
so fortunately most of the cases you can
just tokenize and stream tokenize data
and then you still do
anything around it sometimes you miss
some prediction power if you don't
decompose your feature right classical
example is your email if you want to
strike subtract the domain for example
of the email so we take care of that but
we also i mean imagine we iterate a lot
so we build
all the stuff
all the time
we're also spinning out new flows to
train on pi data straight it just has
different requirements for well
regulation and all that
thank you for questions and thank you
for the talk thank you
[Applause]